what's up everybody I'm Greg Miller
alongside the pride along Island Colin
Moriarty hello Greg Colin yes it's a
PlayStation logo we're at home run our
wheelhouse and definitely we are this of
course Gorillaz game mm-hmm horizon the
long-rumored open-world RPG so it looks
like yeah exactly we don't know for sure
I laid on me what did you think our
first blush or focus it looks at night
I'm really really impressed I this is
with it wasn't for the Last Guardian
this might have been the biggest game of
Playstations conference for me and I
like how they put it like right up in
front yeah Gorillaz well known for
making Killzone people like Killzone
Sony owns gorilla it's cool that they're
able to do something new now they did
make a different game other than
Killzone 2 called an am back in the day
but you know they acknowledged it the
CEO of the studio acknowledged right out
front it's like we're known for this
certain thing and now we get to do
something else this games been in
development or a long time clearly and
it's awesome and the story is really
cool in the fusion of old and new and by
all the new I mean very old and very new
right oh this looks like Manhattan it
isn't I mean doing wrong is over popular
there's different things and you point
out the fact that it looks like the last
Killzone shadow yeah look successful
there's evidence about I'm not saying
that in a literal way it is not
connected oh no no no but I mean like
that that glass and that pristine you
know surface definitely their style yeah
so to get in here like this immediately
like had its hooks in me right you know
what I mean like I look at this and I'm
like yeah alright like this seems like a
cool story that i'd like to get into and
see these these this they go through and
it's you know this tribe of people right
who now live in what used to be our
world but has now been grown over and
done all these different things and why
can I not remember the name that I'm
thinking of enslaved reminds me a bit of
enslaved right we're saying that for
sure yeah it's about a reclaimed land
yeah presumably the stories about
finding out you would have to assume
what happened because something happened
so badly to society in humanity that
they were knocked back to the Stone Age
basically yeah but the weird thing is
that they're fighting robots right as we
jump ahead here like we're out hunting
or out hunting you know and trying to
avoid these giant as robots that are out
here like truant you know and she like
she talks to this one not like it's a
terminator right like she this thing
comes around she runs up she kills it
and she's like
Shh you know I mean like not the way I
would talk to a toaster if I was [ __ ]
kill on a toaster yeah no I think nice
Battlestar Galactica reference I think
that they're more like the herbivore of
the robot whatever that creature was you
see them running by her at some point
yeah and he's afraid of it but she's
trying you know she's attacking these
guys to get their canisters and green
goo off their back I it's just if I feel
the way she communicates and talks about
these robots make them seem more like
they're not they're not our standard
Johnny Phibes they are animals they are
breeding to some extent the universe I
mean that's the whole mystery of the
game and I'm really treated I was like
what the hell is going on in this game
I'm just super curious about it i think
it's i mean we were saying we don't know
for sure but it was rumored that they're
working on an open-world RPG looks
pretty open world to me yeah yeah so
it's just so different than the corridor
shooters it that's what's so exciting
about this is grill has just been making
like pretty bland looking corridor
shooters for a long time with exception
of shadow fall on ps4 which is
definitely a step in a different
direction that was clearly probably
inspired by this yeah I'm or vice versa
uh but now they're making something wide
open and different and it's not the
helghast anymore not in these guns
anymore no that's what's crazy they
didn't you're saying you know it's been
rumored to be open with that destruction
right there right if this what we're
seeing is in an open world you know what
I mean like that's gonna blow people's
mind when they reveal that because right
now they're gonna keep playing in this
like it looks like in slaver it looks
like action or it looks like last of us
really dialed up right in terms of where
humanity is but if you get to the point
where yeah all right now go do this
anywhere on this map you know what I
mean yeah who would war yeah it looks
really I mean I'm I don't know ma'am
that I'm really impressed i want to know
more about this I just fear that this
game is so far off and and that's
unfortunate because they've been working
on for so long and you know I hope it's
no later than the no 2016 but it could
be a 20-17 year that's true the game's
been in development five six years at
that point so yeah you talked about this
game you didn't know it at the time yeah
but you would talked about this game
back in 2011 in GDC yeah when you went
to a kill zone or a gorilla panel so
this game has been incubating for some
time now yeah but I want to get it right
you know what I mean absolutely it
forced out and it seems like according
to what we saw at e3 this year 2016 is
gonna be a big year for PlayStation in
terms of all the
we waited for 2015 not so much not 2015
is quiet as hell it's the year of the
Vita everybody get that Vita ladies
gentle from everything that's awesome
and at e3 hit up gamespot.com / III keep
watching this